in late 2011 hundreds of namibians took
to the tarmac at vendek's airport to
receive remains of their ancestors the
country had endured a long wait these
skulls belonged to the indigenous Herero
and nama who rebelled against german
colonizers and were brutally killed a
century ago the skulls had been housed
the world away in German museums ever
since back then the imperialists called
the land German Southwest Africa
present-day namibia in 1904 the Germans
captured thousands of ethnic Herrero
during the Battle of vato Beck they
forced them into the oume Hecky desert
and sealed it off the prisoners died of
hunger and thirst an estimated 100,000
Herrero were killed fighting the Germans
100 years later a representative of the
German government travelled to Namibia
to deliver the first official apology I
ask you to forgive us our trespasses
precipices and our guilt many say it's
too early to celebrate no reparations
have been made or approved the German
government had refused to label the
Herero Massacre a genocide because the
term was not legally defined until 1948
yet the German parliament recently said
the killing of one and a half million
Armenians by the Turks in 1915 was a
genocide now norbert lammott the
president of the parliament says the
suppression of the Herero rebellion was
genocide - that will increase the
pressure for Germany to take greater
responsibility for its colonial past